we're excited to share a preview of
version 4 of the job search API this is
just a beta preview so everything is
subject to change that being said
there's some cool stuff coming up so
let's dive into it our previous code
samples were all using Version three
so they'll still work if you want to
start from there as always the
documentation has all of the up-to-date
information on which versions are
available and how to use them
version four is currently in beta and
has some cool new advantages that you
can use first up there's now the ability
to use tenants tenants are entities that
let you group companies and jobs instead
of having everything grouped under your
GCP project this way you can easily
isolate tenants without having to create
new GCB projects especially useful for
things like hiring agency and job sites
working with multiple organizations by
default you'll have a tenant ID when you
set up a job search API so if you don't
want to worry about tenants you don't
have to you can continue to use the API
in the same way as version 3 and it'll
always assume the default tenant you can
also create a new tenant with the API
then use that for everything by
explicitly specifying it you can create
as many tenants as you need to organize
your companies and jobs if you're just
looking for your default tenant ID just
create a company without specifying a
tenant and you'll be able to find the ID
in the newly created company's name
besides tenants there's also some new
features around the commute search the
job search API lets you search by a
users preferred commute time by driving
and public transport version 4 adds
walking and biking to this search so you
can give your use an even better
experience when just looking for jobs
just include a commute filter object
when making a search request to filter
the results by the commute parameter
there's more specifics in the
documentation just as important as the
user search experience is your
experience implementing the API that's
why the event handling API has been
created to help make the client event
system easier to integrate this is the
part of the API where you pass in events
from users interacting with the search
so the machine learning models can be
fine-tuned for example when a user
clicks on a job to see more details you
can pass along a view message once you
hook up the events API you can use the
events live stir
tool in the GCP console to make sure
that you see the events as they come in
in addition the data logging Terms and
Conditions have been updated so you can
read exactly how the event data is being
used there's also a new API to create or
update jobs in batches and the client
library is now support G RPC this should
make it easier and give you more ways to
integrate the job search API since this
is all currently in beta there's still
changes coming make sure to check the
documentation for the latest and please
share your feedback thanks for watching
and remember when looking for talent
it's RK to keep your head in the cloud
[Music]